economía en directo América de France 24
Daniela Blandón con nosotros en el
estudio Daniela vamos a hablar de la
visita del presidente chino Arabia
Saudita que tiene intereses económicos
sí Raúl pues
quiere consolidar a Beijing como el
principal socio comercial del Golfo
Pérsico eso ante el alejamiento de
Estados Unidos que ve con mucho recelo
como china está ganando influencia en el
medio oriente sobre todo en proyectos de
infraestructura energética
hoyng fue recibido por el príncipe
heredero Mohamed Bin salman en su
primera visita al reino árabe desde 2016
allí anunció en prensa local en una
columna de opinión el inicio de lo que
llamó una nueva era en las relaciones
binacionales este encuentro cobra mucha
importancia económica si se tiene en
cuenta que china es el mayor consumidor
mundial de commodities y que Arabia
Saudita es el exportador número uno de
petróleo ambos países tuvieron un
Comercio binacional en de 80 mil
millones de dólares haciendo de China el
principal socio comercial de los
sauditas a quienes les compra el 20% de
todo el crudo que consume el gigante
asiático la segunda economía mundial el
líder comunista tiene planeado reunirse
con otros productores de petróleo del
Golfo y aseguró que estos estados eran
un tesoro oculto de energía para la
economía mundial y también son terreno
fértil para el desarrollo de industrias
sobre todo de alta tecnología en lo que
es experto por supuesto este país Así es
Dani seguimos en Asia porque en Corea
del Sur Se le ordenaron a los camiones
en huelga a volver a trabajar sí pues el
gobierno de surcorea de Corea del Sur
endureció hoy todavía más su postura
frente a la huelga de transportistas que
afecta al país hace ya dos semanas la
semana pasada había emitido una orden
ejecutiva que penalizaba aquellos que no
retornarán al trabajo pero solamente
cubría a quienes trabajan para la
cementera esta vez emitió una segunda
orden para otros sectores quienes
permanezcan en huelga podrán ser
penalizados con multas de hasta 30
millones de wones que son
aproximadamente
22.600 dólares o hasta tres años de
prisión escuchemos que dice el gobierno
surcoreano
el gobierno decidió ampliar una orden de
regreso al trabajo en nuestras
industrias siderúrgicas y petroquímica
considerando de manera ilegal los daños
y efectos dominó de la denegación del
transporte colectivo a medida que los
envíos continúan interrumpidos debido a
la suspensión de la logística existe una
posibilidad creciente de que la
producción se interrumpa a partir de
este fin de semana
aterrizamos en nuestra región de América
Latina y el Caribe porque en Venezuela
Volverán los controles de precios
algunos productos Raúl Pues usted lo
debe conocer más que yo que esta
política había sido sin duda hace dos
años Ahora buscan revivir la
argumentando que hay especulación en los
precios de venta al público de algunos
productos
de 40 productos
consumo masivo de la población
se venía alterando la dinámica de precio
de esos productos y después de
conversaciones con los diferentes
sectores que hacen vida en la producción
de estos productos se fijaron un
conjunto de precios que deben constituir
el tope al cual se venden esos productos
considerando tomando en consideración
los costos de producción y tomando en
consideración también ganancias
razonables como lo establece la ley y
para dar un poco de contexto el gobierno
empezó a fijar precios en 2015 una
política que se fue endureciendo hasta
2018 cuando los controles comenzaron a
flexibilizarse en 2020 se fijaron
tarifas sobre 27 alimentos y la semana
pasada la superintendencia para la
defensa de los Derechos socioeconómicos
públicos
borró minutos después de haber publicado
una lista de precios máximos de venta al
público en productos como arroz harina
aceite o azúcar Dani como siempre
Gracias por toda la información
económica mañana con más mañana para
nuestro último programa del año
y volvemos repotenciados para 2023 así
va a ser Dani nosotros vamos a ir
directo a París con arico olavarría